hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead finale video so much
awesome stuff to talk about but real
quick double round of the giveaway
starts now so all you have to do to
enter is be subscriber leave a comment
on this video just careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet I
was really happy with the way things
went down this is my new favorite
Walking Dead finale of any season I
think the biggest surprise is the number
of deaths that did not end up happening
it feels like Scott Gimple had this like
finely tuned algorithm to create a
finale that would be as pleasing as
possible to everyone while at the same
time addressing any potential rage from
the fandom I may have said it before but
Robert Kirkman am see very clearly doing
everything they can to keep Walking Dead
especially with the main cast on the
show as long as possible I'm gonna talk
about the trailer for the spin-off show
at the end of this so let's start with
top 10 moments though number 10
Morgan meets the wolves so apparently
Morgan has been a Jedi Academy this
whole time that we haven't been seeing
him
I like how nonchalant he is when that
first wolf person comes up to him it was
a really great explainer for the culture
of the wolf society in the comics to
call the scavengers but that's basically
what we saw in this episode that group
of people if you have read the comics
and you know what they do Nick's like
what they'll probably end up doing in
season 6 like they probably just follow
the comics please use spoiler tags the
actor who plays Morgan totally not a
surprise showed up on talking dead and
kind of explained what's going on in
Morgan's head he said what he's doing is
is trying to find Rick Rick is like the
only person he knows the person who
helped bring him back to sanity because
when Rick found him the last time we saw
them together
Morgan was at his lowest point he lost
everything he lost his family he had no
sense of self no purpose Rick kind of
helped him get that back
so Morgan has been on a journey to find
senpai Rick it just happens to run into
some creepy pose on the way moving out
to number 9 Michonne in Rick reconcile I
just like the look on Michonne's face at
the beginning of the episode when she's
reacting to what Carol sang like she
doesn't buy any of this [ __ ] and
later is such a heartfelt moment when
she tells Rick no matter what I'm still
with you even if she goes crazy I will
say I am glad that the writers stuck to
their guns like most of the survivors
were preaching a calmer way like they're
like please let's not turn this into
another terminus and just try and take
over and that's pretty much what
happened Rick
found another way but he literally
provided evidence as to why the
Alexandrians needed to man up you're not
ready but you need to get ready right
now because your luck is gonna run out I
didn't do that for them I did that for
you that was such a great line I know a
lot of you were pissed when she did that
last week but yeah I mean she was doing
it to help him moving on to number eight
Oh sunshine you do not get to have both
this is one of my favorite Carol moments
in the episode if Norman Reedus isn't
careful Carol's character is gonna
become way more fun than his in fact I
actually I will say that Carol is now
the most fun character on Walking Dead
I know we're all crossing our fingers
for 'crawl and Enid to have some really
cool adventures next year but but right
now
Carol is toeing the line not only does
Carol make the best cookies in the safe
zone she is also probably the wisest
person there moving on to number seven
Darryl and Erin get caught at the wolves
hideout I love the way the camera
lingered on that that's sign on the side
of the 18-wheeler how the harvest gets
home there were so many awesome things
just inside this one moment that it's
actually hard to compress a tall one you
see all the W's carved into the Walker
head so you're like okay clearly these
are the Wolves here and to Daryl has one
of the best Walker takedowns in the
episode with the chain whip just
whipping the heads off that was my
favorite Walker kill till Rick at the
end of the episode and then all I could
think when Daryl and Erin piled into
that little car was a Velma and Louise
like when they were getting ready to
make a break for it but moving on to
number six Carroll versus porchdick this
was funnier than it was scary like you
have Carroll versus Sam with the cookie
stuff that was a little scarier Carroll
versus Pete though that's just funny
maybe because he's so big any such a
porch dick it's like the best come at me
bro that I've seen in a long time she's
just like we gonna do what are you gonna
do I'm really interested to see if she
keeps the facade of her character up if
she keeps playing that Stepford wife my
other favorite line of the episode was
that Caroline where she said tell him a
story these people are children children
love stories moving on to number five
Morgan saves Daryl and Erin or Thelma
and Louise however you want to think
about him I do like how their
positioning Erin's character for season
six I'm hoping he'll stick around for a
while he's a really interesting guy he
and Daryl is such an odd pairing and now
that you have Morgan in the mix I'm
really interested to see what happens
with that because Morgan isn't so much a
people person but he's really there just
for Rick in that map that map was such
an awesome
reveal I'm not interested in joining
your community I'm actually headed
somewhere else I'm a little lost can you
tell me where we are
during talking debt Norman Reedus
explained that at some point even though
he didn't see it on screen
he thinks that Rick told Darrel about
Morgan so Darrel kind of understands who
Morgan is once he sees the map if it
wasn't clear though since Morgan is
looking for Rick and he found him at the
safe zone
I think Morgan will stay there number
four Gabriel flips his [ __ ] and tries to
sacrifice himself to a walker he is a
really hard character to pin down but
Seth Gilliam is a great actor so I see
why they want to keep him on the show it
just his performance is so great
everyone hates the character but you're
supposed to hate him it's like King
Joffrey on Game of Thrones it's awesome
how he can totally fail at everything he
can fail at Walker assisted suicide all
he has to do is just stand there that's
all he has to do and he can't do that
that look on his face though when he
comes back into the community just like
crazy look in his eyes that is so funny
the minute that Gates didn't close like
you could feel like the tension in the
music just rising in the background just
like the hair on the back of everyone's
neck all over the world just starts to
raise up on to number 3 Glen vs.
Nicholas and Sasha versus Gabriel they
did a really good job like the last half
hour to the episode of like bouncing
these two different scenes off of each
other but because Glen backed off of
Nicholas first I actually thought that
Sasha was gonna go the other way and she
was gonna end up killing Gabriel it
totally it seems like Maggie's gonna
become this angelic figure to Gabriel
he's so brainwashed and she shows him
such compassion that he's probably just
gonna unload on her big-time I hope she
brought some Tylenol Glen though I had
to say I was disappointed that they did
not kill Nicholas that was one of the
big surprises the episode like the
surprise not deaths even Nicholas said
it himself I don't belong here
I think the reason Nicholas wanted to
kill Glen is so that Glen wouldn't tell
everyone what Nicholas did I think he
was just worried the truth would come
out and they would exile him now that
Glen has spared him though I think he'll
try to find some Redemption but he is
still a redshirt when you look at the
big cast of all the people on the show
he is still like at Red Shirts status
for the beginning of season six moving
on to number two porchdick kills Diana's
husband with Michonne sword leading to
Deanna asking Rick to kill porch de
this was a lot of fun because we all
knew it was happening and someone had to
eat it
porchdick was just at the top of the
list was anyone else a little
unsatisfied with the way he went out
like they showed Rick shooting him but
they didn't show the bullet going into
him they didn't show his head splatter
or anything like that it just it felt
like they didn't give us enough time to
savor that moment before Rick looks up
and sees Morgan but ding-dong the porch
dick is gone and finally my number one
moment the Wolves load up their 18
wheelers and get ready to roll out and
find the safe zone if it wasn't clear
where they got those pictures from it
was Aaron's back like they had all of
Aaron's stuff so he had all this
information on on where the safe zone
was pictures of everyone so they're very
well informed about the safe zone season
6 premiere calling it now they're gonna
roll up and unleash all those walkers on
the walls and everyone's wondering now
though is it gonna be like a terminus
situation the beginning of season 5
where it just comes crashing down around
everyone this has all been done in the
comics so if you have read the comics
please use spoiler tags if you're gonna
talk about what happens next and
everyone's asking about negan showing up
I think the first chance we have at
seeing him or seeing a teaser for him is
episode 100 cuz that's the issue number
that he showed up in in the comics
here's my big question for you guys what
was your favorite moment from the finale
and was there anything that made you
really upset like any one that you
really wanted to die that did not die
I'm thinking mostly of Nicholas like
that's the thing that made me the most
upset but think about it this way if
there's gonna be a big battle at the
beginning of season 6 some people are
gonna have to go down and Nicolas just
shot to the top of that list in case you
guys didn't see it here's the teaser for
the spin-off fear The Walking Dead
morning Los Angeles hope you got your
flu shot reports in five states that a
strange virus is going around so if
you're not feeling well go
take care of yourself so if you guys are
a little confused don't worry I feel
like this is just like a teaser for a
teaser they'll probably have real
footage of Comic Con to probably venire
the pilot episode at Comic Con the show
itself is taking place in Los Angeles
and it picks up in the earliest days of
the apocalypse
so we'll start to see the Walker
breakout and then it's kind of jump
forward in time till it catches up with
a timeline of the main show so the
show's will run concurrently eventually
but maybe not till like season 2 season
3 the first season is only gonna be six
episodes it's gonna premiere at the end
of the summer basically six weeks before
the season six premiere the main show
I'm totally gonna do a Q&A for this
tomorrow also that's what I'll name the
giveaway winners if there's any specific
bonus videos you guys want me to do now
that we're heading to the offseason just
let me know in the comments in case you
haven't seen it you can click here for
my top 10 Daryl Dixon moments and you
can click here for all my Walking Dead
Season 5 videos thank you so much
watching let's all high-five I'll see
you guys tomorrow